hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from 2003 between peter
heinen nelson and luke mcshane i'm
showing this game as uh you guys have
probably already saw the interview chat
based india made with peter heinen
nelson but also with vladimir podkin uh
the the chief trainer of yani palmishi
for the world chess championship match
2021 so i just wanted to uh in case you
haven't do check it out it will be the
first link and the second link in the
description below uh so the interview uh
by chessbase india by uh with uh peter
heinen nielsen and vladimir podkin uh if
you guys want to learn a bit more about
what happened during the world
championship what happened behind the
scenes it's a very extensive interview
uh and uh well i i do not want to repeat
anything that was said in there so i
just decided to
show you one of uh one of peter's games
as i thought this was a really fun one
uh and just invite you to check out the
interviews now it's interesting uh this
is uh peter's eighth world chess
championship title and
what's also very interesting is that not
only did he work for both anand and
magnus carlson
but during their first match in 2013 uh
when carlson first challenged cross uh
anand for the title uh he did not work
for for either of them so he only
started working with magnus in 2014. so
interestingly as soon as he stepped down
as anand's uh second uh anand lost the
title and uh well so far uh he's been in
every world championship match magnus
played and magnus uh you know retains
the title every time so uh
definitely uh something peter has up his
sleeve that is you know allowing these
champions to just to stay on top but
that being said do check it out it's a
really awesome interview i've watched it
in its entirety so i i do recommend it
and let's check out this game it's a
very short one but it's uh you know very
enjoyable one uh so peter with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have knight to
f6 he's facing a very strong english
grandmaster luke mcshane no doubt to all
of you i have heard of him uh we have c4
g6 and now knight to c3 we have d5 so a
normal groomfield defense c captures on
d5 we have knight captures uh and e4 now
chasing away the knight of course we
have a captain c3 captures captures and
now bishop to g7
is pretty much always played here but
mcshane goes for the uh sort of an early
deviation with c5 i don't know the exact
difference this makes because obviously
you have to be very strong to
uh to take advantage of this but uh
maybe there really isn't any maybe it's
just uh you know different move order
but i doubt it because in the database
bishop to g7 is just like 20 000 games
and um you know c5 maybe like a thousand
games but okay uh it doesn't really
matter because they transpose into the
the standard line we have bishop to c4
bishop to g7 now the bishop is fine
herod uh controlling this very long
diagonal knight to e2 now preparing the
castle also adding more support to the
center knight to c6 black also fights
for the center and now bishop to e3 so
this is kind of the theme of this
opening we're fighting for that center
and now you could just castle and
continue the game but black decides to
relieve some of the tension in the
center he plays c captures on d4 c
captures and now queen to a5 check now
what does he want with this uh check
well he's asking why do you want to
block with the queen do you want to play
king to f1 and play some sort of a
game without the the early castles or do
you want to move the bishop back which
kind of
forces you to to waste the tempo yeah
and also uh you will not be defending
your d4 square as properly as you are
now so okay bishop back to d2 attacking
the queen queen back to d8 now with some
pressure on the d4 square and now white
uh
either goes back but that's like saying
okay i'm very happy with the draw here
uh or he advances d5 like uh it happened
in this game now what do you do here
obviously you are offering the rook for
a knight but not really if black
captures the rook white of course will
not capture on c6 white will capture the
bishop here attack the black rook on h8
and now after you tend to the rook of
course we're going to capture the knight
on c6 and white is just winning so
knight the e5 has to be played now the
bishop here is attacked but it doesn't
matter just bishop c3 and now
of course this is uh
very good for white because if you
capture on c4 we're gonna capture on g7
and okay you don't lose any material for
example queen to a for check you can
block bishop the seven queen captures on
c4 we're gonna capture here but after
white castles uh white has excellent
central control the rook is in g7 the
king is not castling so this would be
pretty bad for for black
so instead we have just castles uh and
now comes the bishop back to b3 so we
don't have to worry about this tension
here queen to b6 uh with some tricky
lines possible as df two pawn might
become a little bit weak so there might
be some ideas of maybe knight to g4
attacking the bishop here and also
threatening the f2 pawn but it doesn't
really work uh as peter will show so he
plays f4 attacks the knight and now if
you try something like this yes it looks
very scary queen f2 bishop captures and
c3 are the threats but just bishop d4
and you don't really have all that much
once everything gets traded off captures
captures captures white
you know has this beautiful center the
pieces are nicely developed you can just
castle and the black can't really hope
to
get all that much out of the position
here so instead after f4 we have knight
back to d7 and now we have a trade
captures captures and rook to c1
putting the rook on this uh only open
file on the board for the moment uh and
uh well preparing some very nasty stuff
because uh
the dark square bishops have left the
board and black really has some dark
square weaknesses around his king so you
want the white queen to
somehow gain control of this diagonal
so rook to d8
and now comes rook to c4 we moved the
rook and now we prepare to bring the
queen over to this diagonal e5 now uh
and here just queen to a1 uh not
allowing the capture now the the pawn
cannot move uh and uh interestingly uh
luke mcshane had this position after
this game some some three months uh uh
against another player jonathan parker
in the european cup and there he played
rook to e8 but here in the game against
nilsson he played f6 he uh well not only
defends the e5 pawn but he's now also
preparing e captures on f4 because now
the pawn can capture but there is one
thing that makes this move a bit of a
problem uh not just uh you know they
often say that you know f6 isn't uh
the best move in most positions but uh
for this position it is true uh because
now we have queen to c3 and by playing
f6 you of course weaken the seventh rank
and now rook to c7 uh well it's not an
uh it's not a very pleasant move to have
to face so here e captures on f4 black
continues with his plan knight captures
on f4 and now knight to e5 attacking the
rook on c4
rook the c7 check of course this was our
plan all along and now king to h8 and
now this video will have two very nice
positive video moments so this is the
first one feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only winning move
for white here it's not an easy one to
spot so while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
because it's uh well you really have to
see deep into the position to you know
uh spot such a move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show the move
is rook to f1 that's that's the good
stuff as you see the rook is cutting off
the king from the seventh rank so it's
uh uh well for the moment the king
cannot help out with the defense of the
f6 pawn and the f6 pawn is pretty much
the only thing that keeps black alive in
this position because with the rook
controlling the seventh rank the queen
controlling this diagonal if we if we
remove the f6 pawn it just all falls
apart so uh black continues with bishop
to d7 of course you want to cut off the
rook's
influence on the seventh rank and also
you want to bring this rook into the
game and try and trade everything off
because white is very just very very
strong here so knight the e6 uh putting
pressure on the rook here and also
saying yes by all means capture on uh
on e6 but if black does this of course
we don't capture the bishop we just play
rook captures on f6 and now look at this
how how are you defending this even with
the absolute best defense by black which
is queen to b4 looks very odd it's like
you're giving up a queen but not really
you will win back the queen with this
fork uh but even with this for example
knight to d3 checking e2 knight captures
on b4 uh after white gets this beautiful
pass pawn it's just game over there's no
defending this this we're coming to f7
we're just gonna harass the king uh
along the uh seventh rank and then well
uh you are not escaping this attack so
this is out of the question so instead
rook d the c8 was played getting the
rook out of harm's way attacking the
rook on c7
but now comes rook captures on f6 and
now white achieved everything white
hoped for when he played rook to f1 he
eliminated the f6 pawn and there's no
good defense against the well the queen
just controlling this diagonal so here
we have rook captures on c7 attacking
the queen uh but this uh will simply uh
not be enough so feel free to pause the
video and again find the only winning
move in the position while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on not doing
anything weird like recapturing on c7
even though this is fine for you to draw
the game it's not enough for you to win
the game and for those of you who found
the winning idea that is rook to f8
check congratulations this is uh the
absolute best this is a forced made in
four and it's interesting how both pause
the video moments were with the rook
just rook to f1 then rook to f8 but you
know it happens so there is no move
black in play here it's only rook
captures on f8 that this is the only
possible move as the g7 square is
covered by the knight so rook captures
and here queen captures and e5 was
played and it was in this position on
move 27 that luke mcshane resigned the
game uh as there is nothing more to be
done here you could start giving up some
material but basically it's just king g8
queen g7 checkmate and that's it
so there you go a wonderful game by uh
by peter heinen nelson uh the head coach
of the magnus carlson wheelchair
championship team uh also as magnus puts
it the only adult in the room you can
see that he's not only a a great coach
he also prepares very very well for the
games and can create a a masterpiece
such as this one so hope you enjoyed the
game and also uh you know do check it
out do check out both of the interviews
if you have the time it will be a time
well spent
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
begum farida gordon t wright andy
chamberlain alan dropkin and jack obede
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and everything else that
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day